you have Maurice Ashley with a special
guest a frequent visitor at her shows
it's always great to have with us Kitty
right there yes kitty Radcliffe for the
president of explore st. Louis she has
been named one of the most influential
businesswomen in all of st. Louis as
well as serving in on many boards in the
area kitty welcome back to the show
thanks Maurice for the viewers who sadly
have not watched the show enough please
let us remind them remind us and inform
them as to what the mission of explore
st. Louis is well we generate economic
activity for our community through
tourism so it's our goal to attract
people to st. Louis and show them all
the great things that are to do in our
community and we do a pretty good job of
that because we have a great product to
sell st. Louis is a great place to visit
indeed tell us why the chest the the
interest in chest we're explore st.
Louis of course we know that it's become
the chest capital of the country that's
something a special pride for st.
Louisans it is the chest capital of a
country we like to you know we're in
sales we pretty much just say it's the
chest capital of the world
[Laughter]
and it's a wonderful thing for this
community because it's really grown the
story is so great it's grown from
nothing it's grown from chess as an
interest for you know a very small group
of people in the community and not very
high-profile it's just something that
the entire community is engaged and the
entire community rallies around there's
chess in the schools
there's chess for tourists there's you
know this this great competition that
happens every year where the Chess Club
and scholastic Center invites not only
the Sinquefield Cup but many other
championships to come to this community
and the showcase that we have on a
worldwide basis to to your audience this
is something that we've never had before
and so we love it yes also I know there
are lots of things to do here in st.
Louis I managed to go to the Art Museum
finally and saw the great Egyptian
sunken treasure
sunken cities exhibit that was something
fantastic to go to we're seeing images
here off st. Louis on our screen I know
you have some
things going on including the arch
finally opening the arch grounds
completely redone 380 million dollars it
was a long construction project maybe a
little longer than people anticipated
that it would take but it was
beautifully done and it was completely
reopened to the public about a month and
a half ago and it's a spectacular new
museum and outdoor amphitheater for
events and a really great way to
understand the history of this country
and that's what the arch is all about it
was the Gateway to the West and it was a
gateway to the westward Express
exploration of the country and that
story's told really well in the museum
I've got to get to it for sure I'm gonna
be back here soon as well so I'm making
a special day of that not a bad city
indeed tell us what's the next for say
for Explorer st. Louis well there's a
lot of great things that come up every
week like this upcoming weekend we've
got a wonderful IndyCar Series
championship that's happening at gateway
Motorsports
hundred thousands of people will be
there to see that this weekend there's
there's a lot of great things always
going on regardless of what you're
interested in but really the next big
huge project from a construction
standpoint and the the the reopening of
a treasure like the arch grounds was is
the all the work that's been done at st.
Louis Union Station which is a train
station what that was designed by
Theodore Link one of the great
architects the United States at the at
the last turn of the century so opened
in the late 1800s it's a hotel but right
now it's undergoing a transformation for
a brand new six hundred almost six
hundred thousand gallon aquarium that
will be open in 2019 along with one of
those big huge wheels you know 200 foot
tall wheels and a fire and light show on
the lake out and back and everything
else that they're doing it's a hundred
a million dollar project so we're really
excited about that that does sound very
exciting something to ask you did you
finally start beefing up that chess game
no I have two that I don't I keep saying
we have to I have to tell you the first
time I met Rex Sinquefield and he asked
me if I played chess and I said I made a
joke and I said I played checkers he
didn't laugh all right we gotta get you
one of the assets Aaron's books right
you know to get you going
thank you so much kitty Radcliffe
president explore st. Louis for more on
explore st. Louis you can go to explore
st. Louis that calm always a pleasure to
have you thank you nice to be here